[Music]
a new lawsuit accuses tech giant google
of racial bias against its black workers
april curley a former google employee
claims in her lawsuit that the company
steered black hires toward lower paying
jobs using their knowledge while denying
them chances to advance she says that
she was fired after she spoke out lilia
luciano spoke to curley about her
experience working for google
it was my dream job that dream for april
curly who joined google in 2014 meant
leading the change she wished to see in
big tech
my role was to
engage with historically black colleges
and universities and recruit some of the
brightest
most talented black students and she did
i brought over 500 talented qualified
students to google to be hired but in a
lawsuit she filed against google she
claims she and those student recruits
were pigeon-holed into dead-end jobs
received lower pay and were often
dismissed as being not googly enough
what were they saying it is a fit test
and it is to see if
the wording normally is would you grab a
beer with that person it's a very unfair
metric she claims in the suit that she
and other black employees endured micro
and macro aggressions
i was told that i was intimidating
and that i was never tapped for
leadership
opportunities because my white managers
said that they were afraid of me curly
says after she complained about her
treatment she was put on a performance
review and ultimately lost her job
cbs legal analyst ricky clemen
what should be most concerning to google
about
what this case lays out the worst fact
for google on the face of the complaint
is that they terminated her after she
raised issues of racial discrimination
so it looks like it's retaliatory
civil rights attorney ben crump is
representing curly in the lawsuit google
has been referred to as one of the
greatest disruptors
in the past century where it's not
enough to disrupt technology if you
don't also disrupt racism and
discrimination
beyond the lawsuit reuters reported that
california's department of fair
employment and housing last year
launched its own investigation into the
company's treatment of black women in
response google said they would
investigate any concerns to make sure
our workplace is representative and
equitable
in the wake of the social justice
protests of 2020 google launched a
multi-million dollar initiative to hire
more black workers google didn't respond
to a request for comment but it told the
washington post in the past it doesn't
agree with curly's description of her
termination the company's annual
diversity report shows the number of
black employees hired went from 5.5 in
2020 to 8.8
last year but curly says representation
isn't just about hiring it's about
retention
and what does it do not having people of
color in the room it violates their core
value number one
to work with great people
well great people include black and
brown people
for cbs mornings lilia luciano san
francisco
so quite a story there quite a lawsuit
there may be more to it so reuters and
exclusive back in december spoke to
seven current and former black employees
female at google who all felt
marginalized
the turnover rate is higher than other
groups and as lilia mentioned the civil
rights regulator there in california is
investigating so things may be happening